Der achte und äußerste Planet des Sonnensystems
ist Neptun: Und dieser Gasriese mit einem
Durchmesser von knapp 50.000 Kilometern gibt
uns immer noch große Rätsel auf.
Zwar haben schon die Aufnahmen der Raumsonde
Voyager 2 vor 30 Jahren gezeigt, dass in seinen
oberen Gas-Schichten kräftige Wirbelstürme
toben.
Doch noch immer ist unklar, wie genau sie
entstehen.
Jetzt hat das Hubble-Weltraumteleskop einen
neuen mysteriösen, dunklen Wirbelsturm auf
dem Neptun entdeckt.
Kommen wir dem Phänomen damit jetzt auf die
Spur?
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
spannende Sciencevideos abonniert den Kanal
nur dann verpasst ihr keins herzlich willkommen!
Den neuen laut NASA äußerst “mysteriösen”
Wirbelsturm auf dem Neptun hatte das Hubble-Weltraumteleskop
schon im Herbst 2018 entdeckt, doch erst jetzt
hat die NASA diese Entdeckung öffentlich
gemacht.
Und der Sturm ist nicht ohne: Er tobt auf
der nördlichen Hemisphäre des Neptun und
wird wohl mehrere Jahre andauern, so vermuten
es zumindest die NASA-Fachleute.
Um den Wirbelsturm herum sind Wolken in hellweiß
zu beobachten.
Diese entstehen durch die aufgewirbelte Luft,
die abkühlt und einfriert.
Nach Vermutung von Experten könnte es sich
hierbei um kondensiertes Methan handeln.
Vergleichbar mit dem Wasserdampf auf der Erde.
Dazu heißt es auch von Seiten des “Space
Telescope Science Institute”: “Diese Wolken
ähneln solchen Wolken mit pfannenkuchenförmigem
Erscheinungsbild, die man sieht, wenn Luft
über den Bergen auf der Erde aufgewirbelt
wird”.
Solche Stürme auf dem Neptun sind eher selten,
auch wenn der Planet wohl einer der windigsten
Orte unseres Sonnensystems ist.
Es handelt sich hier um den insgesamt sechsten
Sturm auf dem Neptun, den wir Menschen mitbekommen
haben.
Vier davon wurden bereits durch das Hubble-Teleskop
aufgespürt.
Diesmal wurde der Wirbel bei Routineuntersuchungen
entdeckt.
Dazu die NASA: “Diese Bilder sind Teil einer
Reihe von Hubble-Schnappschüssen von Neptun
und Uranus, die die Wettermuster auf diesen
weit entfernten, kalten Planeten aufzeichnen”.
Doch das Seltsame daran: Alle bisher beobachteten
Wirbel unterscheiden sich extrem - und zwar
in Form, Größe und Wanderungsbewegung.
Ihre einzige Gemeinsamkeit ist wohl lediglich,
dass sie nur einige Jahre existieren.
Anders als der “Große Rote Fleck” des
Jupiters, der schon seit Jahrhunderten existiert.
Doch der aktuelle Wirbelsturm ist nicht ohne:
Er soll laut NASA einen Durchmesser von 6800
Meilen, also umgerechnet knapp 11.000km) haben.
Zum Vergleich: Der Durchmesser der Erde beträgt
12.700 km.
Die ersten beiden Wirbelstürme konnten bereits
1989 entdeckt werden - damals fand nämlich
der Erkundungsflug der NASA Voyager-2-Sonde
statt.
Spannend war auch die Untersuchung eines Wirbelsturmes
durch das Hubble-Teleskop über einen längeren
Zeitraum hinweg.
Und zwar von 2015 bis 2017.
Damals ging man davon aus, dass sich der Sturm
von 2015 am Neptun Äquator auflösen würde.
Doch die Simulationen der Fachwelt lagen komplett
falsch.
Der Sturm zog in die entgegengesetzte Richtung:
Er verblasste langsam, als er Richtung Südpol
zog.
Das macht noch einmal deutlich, dass wir tatsächlich
kaum etwas über diese Wirbel wissen: Weder
wie sie sich bilden noch wie schnell sie sich
drehen.
Doch die NASA ist optimistisch und glaubt,
das Rätsel bald lösen zu können.
Denn schon Bilder aus der Vergangenheit zeigten
eine “erhöhte Wolkenaktivität” auf dem
Neptun.
Und das ist die Schlußfolgerung der NASA
dazu: “Die Bilder zeigen, dass sich die
Stürme vermutlich tiefer in der Atmosphäre
des Neptuns entwickeln und erst sichtbar werden,
wenn der Sturm seinen Höhepunkt und höhere
Lagen erreicht”.
Große Hoffnung wird weiter in das Hubble-Teleskop
gesetzt.
Es besitzt die notwendigen UV-Kameras und
die Auflösung, um das noch so unberechenbare
Wetter auf dem Neptun sichtbar machen zu können.
So sollen die äußeren Planeten auch weiterhin
langfristig beobachtet und analysiert werden.
Laut NASA könnten dadurch atmosphärische
Trends nachvollzogen werden und “verbliebene
Geheimnisse dieser fernen Welten” gelüftet
werden.
Die Spannung bleibt also.
Auf dem Jupitermond Europa wurden Geysire
nachgewiesen.
Er gilt damit als einer der aussichtsreichen
Kandidaten für Leben.
Dafür hier draufklicken, anschauen und abonnieren.
Bis dann bleibt dran!